depuis la semaine dernière les matinées
commence à manquer blement de la même
manière à grand-anse c'est à dire avec
les apnéistes ils ont la lourde tâche de
ramener à terre les tortues qui se cache
au fond de l'eau première difficulté
sont meilleurs apnéistes et vont plus
vite que nous donc il faut essayer
d'être ré efficace et une fois sorti du
bateau la tortue est pesé puis un long
parcours l'attend sous les regards
ébahis des enfants
l'animal sera ainsi scanner puis on lui
prendra un morceau de chair un morceau
des cahiers un peu de son sang
rien d'extraordinaire sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il vient une nouveauté
aujourd'hui il ya it from her qui
essayent de développer des balises qui
sont moins onéreuse que celle du marché
et qui permettrait de suivre localement
les tortues donc pas forcément sur des
grandes migrations parce que c'est des
balises qui vont être détecté par des
antennes qui vont être posés à terre de
quoi ravir damien chevalier déjà très
stressée faut qu'on reste tous trois
comme moi le promets ce chercheur du
cnrs dirige ses campagnes de prélèvement
des tortues marines et en martinique
depuis près de dix ans en plus du volet
pédagogique cette nouvelle opération est
pour lui le meilleur moyen de protéger
tout l'écosystème marin de la martinique
et même plus encore je prends l'exemple
aussi des tortues luth qui se nouait ce2
de méduses une tortue luth fait 400 kg à
se nouer de son poids en méduse chaque
jour donc vous imaginez aussi sur
l'écosystème si longtemps qu'il
disparaissait l'impact que ça pourrait
avoir aussi sur le niveau des poissons
et donc sur la pêche sommes justement en
martinique mais ailleurs aussi grâce à
ces nouvelles balises des données
précieuses sur le trajet la vitesse ou
encore la profondeur à laquelle vont les
tortues seront ainsi enregistrer et
analyser notamment par l'équipe des
explorations de monaco cet organe
monégasque de recherche scientifique
n'est pas dans nos eaux par hasard
monaco n'a pas d'ambition politique
c'est pas un acteur sur l'échiquier
international qui va les gêner les
grands pays
du coup quand monaco porte une parole
particulière notamment sur la protection
de l'environnement comme si désintéressé
monaco est entendue on sait désormais
par exemple que la tortue verte peut
nager jusqu'à 35 kilomètres à l'heure
mais les données recueillies aujourd'hui
nécessiteront plusieurs heures danalyse
en attendant il est un objectif
immédiatement atteint celui de la
sensibilisation des plus jeunes
[Musique]